hello everyone and welcome back to the
candidates tournament it's round 14 the
penultimate round and it's alexander
grishok versus anishigiri and this is
the game that could potentially give us
the challenger of magnus carlsen in
november
as geary now absolutely must win if he
doesn't then uh yani ponchi is the
challenger since you already seen the
previous video
so let's see how he does he has the
black pieces and he needs a win
in this round and hopefully in next one
as well so grishok has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 we have knight to
f6 by geary
c4 we have uh e6 knight to f3 and now
you could play a lot of different ideas
here but gary goes for b6 he goes for
the queen's indian defense
uh and this is something that we
mentioned ever since alpha zero
completely destroyed
the uh queens indian defense that um
it's probably not
playable on that level but for humans
you know if you prepare something
uh for your opponent then it seems to be
playable and this is
of course why geary uses it in the
candidates tournament so here
uh we have g3 preparing to counter black
slides where bishop would bishop the g2
both players fiance their light square
bishops and now
bishop to b for with check bishop to d2
and now c5 so nothing new here this has
all been played before
uh we have bishop captures c captures
doubling uh
the b pawn but you will play a uh a5 in
the future maybe even a4 and those pawns
could be very strong
so here we have castles by both players
castles castles and the
knight b to d2 nicely continuing
development
black does the same we have d6 queen to
b3 now attacking the pawn
and this is what we had in mind a5 so
this is what we replaced with a3
trying to undermine that pawn and now
knight to a6 point being that if now
captures knight can capture and this is
now
uh well a wonderful position for black
you have a very nicely placed knight on
b4
and white it doesn't really have all
that much to show for so instead of
capturing here of course uh
sasha just continues developing we have
rook f2d1
uh and now queen to a7 developing the
queen connecting the rooks and now
knight the e1 uh offering a trade of
light square bishops uh which giri goes
for we have bishop captures
and here's a very interesting uh moment
in the game where
grisha can capture with the king but
also with the knight
he captured with the king and capturing
the k with the king is a completely new
move in this position and it's very
interesting because there are
i think around 17 games that reach this
exact same position
and one of the more notable ones uh is
uh from the uh max
memorial in 1987 anatoly karpa world
champion anatoly karpov had this
position against victor korchnoy
uh and he also uh captured with the
knight and he won that game very nicely
and very quickly i think in some
15 moves after capturing this bishop but
grishok probably knows about that game
and about the other games as well and
probably why he decided to play king
captures maybe to avoid
anish's preparation regarding this
matter so king captures on g2
already a completely new game as of move
14.
so here we have h5 uh in the future you
you can play something like h4 maybe try
and bust open the position here
knight to c2 uh and now comes b captures
on a3 we have b
captures on a3 and now rook a to b8 so
defending the b5
the b6 pawn uh we have e4 grabbing more
space in the center and now giri strikes
in the center with e5
we have queen to d3 defending the d4
pawn and now
knight to c7 shifting the knight over to
e6 with rook 8 to b1
uh and now knight to e6 as planned
putting more pressure
on the d4 pawn and now rook to b5 so
that's a very nicely placed rook there
putting more pressure on the e5 pawn
also at some point you might even
consider rook d to b1 putting more
pressure on the b6 pawn
here we have rook f the e8 by giri and
now comes
h4 i just uh solidifying on the king
side gear replace
g6 and now even f3 and this is a
seemingly a weakening of the position
but not really as
uh it's not really that kind of a
position where black can just you know
sacrifice something and attack the pawn
is just uh improving white's uh
uh situation here in the center so here
now we have knight back to d7 by anish
and now knight to f1 shifting that
knight over to e3
uh we have capture sunday for gary
breaks the tension in the center
knight captures in the now knight to e5
and now uh the queen is under attack so
queen back to e2
and now knight captures on d4 we have
rook captures and knight to c6 now
chasing away the rook
and you have done you have done some
progress here but
white's position is still a little bit
better
the the pieces are more active okay this
knight not doing all that great now
but he can come to e3 for example to d5
very easy
easily and or maybe e3 maybe g4 is an
idea also in the future
so here rook back to d1 and now queen
the e6 so what do you play here
uh knight the e3 as planned this knight
is now a wonderful piece here
uh and here giri played knight to e7
and this move will come back to haunt
him i believe for a very long time
uh it's it's a hard position uh for
black definitely but
knight to e5 seems to be the most
resilient idea
although even this isn't all that great
uh because we're just gonna
double here on on the d file go after
this d6 pawn
and after let's say rugby to d8 to
defending this pawn we're gonna play
queen to d2
now with a triple attack here and it's
just a bad position for black there's no
way to defend this
uh if you try something like queen d7 uh
it doesn't really matter we're just
going to capture
queen captures rook captures the queen
captures rook captures rook captures
and now if rook to c8 with a double
attack on the rook here we don't trade
with rook captures we go back
and then we just play this position
we're up a pawn and you know we're just
gonna bring the king closer to the
action push
push back the knight and just enjoy a
superior game so this is
probably the best gear he has but he
wanted more he played knights the e7
uh controls the f5 square now wants the
wants to push f5
but this doesn't really work all that
great for him
so if you wanna uh figure out what
grisha played here
uh feel free to pause the video and try
to find uh well a reasonable
move here for white while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding uh
either queen to d2 or queen to b2 both
are
very nice moves just going after those
pawns uh grisha played queen to d2
and now you have serious problems here
because you can't
defend this uh pawn with the rook
because this pawn falls and if you
defend it
with this rook then we start attacking
with the g4 and this is the problem
constantly for black
uh captures is a threat here because the
rook also covers that
um h5 square so black simply cannot
allow this
if you play some like knight to c6 we're
just going to capture trade everything
off captures move the king bring the
rook to g1
the queen has a very clear axis the
knight can come to f5
i'm sure there's like 10 different ways
you you can win this position so instead
after this g4 move we would have to play
something like h captures which is just
bad because you allow knight captures
and then a lot of different ideas become
possible the knight
and the queen both control the h6 square
you can play h5
then you can maybe play knight h6 check
uh you could bring
the rook very easily into the game if
the position opens up so this would just
be winning for white
and no doubt sasha would have very
little problems
converting this so instead after queen
to d2 anish tried
f5 as this was the plan and now comes uh
queen captures on d6 there's no point in
waiting with this and you don't want to
capture with the queen because rook
captures and then you lose this pawn as
well if you try defending that
then you no longer defend the g6 spawn
so that's a pretty big
issue so after this we have knight to c6
and
then uh comes e captures on f5 and this
is a
really a wonderful move because if the
knight is captured then of course queen
captures on g6 and black's entire
position falls apart
and the white king is perfectly safe
here for example if king to h8 we just
play f6 and that's it we either deliver
checkmate
or you can try something but not much if
this uh okay
for example if rook to g8 you don't have
queen to h6 because the queen covers
that
but there's still the rook i know you
forgot about this rook for the second
time now but rook captures on h5 does
exist
and that's it queen h6 this is just
checkmate or queen capture it doesn't
really matter
so instead after e captures on f5 we
have g captures
the knight for the moment cannot be
captured and then only now queen
captures an e6
eliminate the defender of the f5 pawn
rook captures and
now knight captures on f5 and now you're
simply up two pawns
and this is simply too much especially
in a classical game
and uh well not not much can be done
here
gear we played knight to e5 he will of
course fight on
now the c4 pawn is under attack but now
rook to d6
attacking the the rook here uh we have
rook back to it if you trade the knight
captures defends the pawn here so of
course black cannot afford any more
trades
uh we have rook back to e8 and now rook
to d4
just nicely defending that also you have
support for uh g4
at any time so knight to c6 attacking
the rook
rook back to d2 now not allowing any
rook to e2 lifts
so here we have rook beat d8 uh
offering a trade here and uh sasha very
happily uh obliges rook captures rook
captures and now
uh we don't go rook rook capture spawn
because then you allow some rook d to
check and then maybe rook d3
with some attacks here it's all lost for
black but
you don't want to give him any chances
so here rook d5
and now comes rook captures on d5 c
captures we have knight to e5 and now
knight to d6
uh we have king to f8 and uh it was um
uh in in this moment that both players
have reached time control so
you know time is no longer an issue in
this game i don't think it ever was i
think giri was maybe playing a bit
faster
to make uh sasha lose more time quickly
uh but if that was the case it didn't
work out all that well
so came to f2 gerishuk starts bringing
the key into the game
king e7 attacks the knight knight b5 and
now king to f6 we
have king e3 uh the pawns are just two
two too many in number
uh we have king to f5 now knight d6
check
king back to f6 king to e4 now you
cannot uh
you know prevent the white king from uh
going forward knight d7
now king to d4 we have king to e7 now
knight to b5 all of these squares are
nicely covered so the black king can't
really enter the game from here
uh king to f6 and now knight to c3
so what do you what do you do now not
much you can we have king to f5
now knight to e4 and again really no
moves here
for black king to g6 was played but now
g4
we have b5 trying to create maybe a past
pawn maybe with captures and a4 maybe
maybe it's possible in some
crazy universe but here uh sasha just
played knight to c5
and he was in this position uh on move
51 that
anish geary resigned the game and a
victory for alexander grishouk which
goes a long way because uh this means
that
uh one whole round before the the
candidates and
uh yanni pognishi is the challenger to
magnus carlsen in november
so yes we do have a challenger magnus
will be playing against yannie ponnishin
and that's uh well that's simply uh i
think it's going to be an amazing match
uh oh
it would be an amazing match whoever won
the candidates tournament but
uh specifically because of uh nepo's uh
you know
weird weird style of play i think it's
gonna be uh the
the craziest one uh perhaps so here
basically you resign because after you
play anything let's say captures
captures
you can't trade because i mean you're
down two pawn so you'd have to go back
knight b8 or knight
f eight doesn't really matter then comes
d6 and that's it
the pawn is just winning this is the
square is covered if you try and
help out with the king d7 king here now
we start pushing this pawn you can
you simply cannot stop all of them so
gary tried uh he didn't work out and you
know uh
all of a sudden he was down two pawns
and you know it was just over
uh so tough break for geary he had his
chance but
you know that's why the candidates
tournament is the candidates tournament
you have to be
the best and you know even though you
could be the best for the entire year
and then you play the candidates
tournament and then you just have a
terrible tournament
like for example what happened to being
lyran uh but you know
that's kind of the point of the
candidates turning and nepo was
definitely the best here and uh
you know he won the candidates one whole
round before the tournament ended which
uh i can't recall if it happened i don't
know if you guys remember last time
in the candidates when magnus was
playing in 2013
it wasn't up until the the very last
game that he knew that he was gonna you
know
uh be the challenger to the vishwanathan
island
uh but yeah also one very interesting
thing if you guys are interested
um and nipple is uh well the only top 10
or maybe even the top 12
or 20 player or maybe even the top 100
player that has a positive score against
magnus carlsen in classical time format
i think
i could be wrong here but i think nepo
defeated magnus four times in classical
chess and magnus only defeated nipple
once or maybe twice i don't know stopped
counting after a while but he
is one of the i i don't think he's the
only person uh
to have a positive score against magnus
and classical as someone also mentioned
this on twitter but i think out of the
the the top 100 i think he is the
the only person but not only that uh he
and the opponent she also has a positive
score against uh
vishwanathan anand against vladimir
kramnik uh against gary kasparov
and against anatoly karpov okay against
kasparov and carl for those were not
classical games those
rapid games but interestingly against a
lot of you know
famous world champions uh nipple has a
positive score
so we'll see what happens in november
slash december it's going to be really
awesome and we will of course cover the
last round of the tournament even though
it no longer affects the results
uh yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
matthew benoit the brad rice
raffle karnatak tiberius and craig wall
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens
in the chess world thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day